今天分享的课堂内容是古风歌词里的修辞学
应用
古风歌它有古诗词的韵味
它是最适合用修辞学来表达意境
而且修辞学运用得当的话
会非常的俊永
非常的耐听
所以古风歌基本上你可以理解成中国风歌曲
古风歌曲它有一种民族的情怀
有东方的色调
那这样子的一个创作的形态跟类别
我在想
他永远会在华语流行音乐里面占有一席之地
接下来先跟各位同学分享什么是修辞学
文学创作里面
除了平铺直述的一个形容词汇之外
他需要借助修辞的形式把文字转介隐喻美化
这样子的一个步骤叫修辞
就是把文字修改颠覆了它的词性
或是赋予它一个间接的意涵
这种意涵会美化了文字的空间
很特别哦
待会一一介绍给同学们了解
所以呢你看吧
我们的歌词创作班居然还有一堂课
专门在教古风歌曲的创作
很值得吧
接下来先分享修辞学的修辞
词性有哪一些的结构
修辞学的类型非常的多元
这也让歌词经由修辞学的修饰之后
得到了更多意境的表达与转换
接下来请大概的介绍一下它有哪一些类别
譬如感叹比喻转化排比
花式转品
回文倒装摹写
引用映衬
设问顶针以及借贷等等
非常的多
但是记住同学们前几堂的课程一再的强调
我们不要为了韵脚而韵脚
不要为了换韵而换韵
不要为了创意而去更改歌名
一切都要看世界性
一切都要看整个架构的一种必要性
修辞学也是不要为了修辞而修辞
有时候故意修辞进去
那个词句是逻辑是不顺畅的
接下来我会用两首中国风的歌词创作
来做一个范例
跟各位同学好好的讲解
修辞学如何运用在歌词的结构里
首先我们分享的是发如雪这首歌词
我现在从一开始的歌词开始
简介有用到修辞学的
我就会停顿
跟大家做一个逐步的讲解
狼牙乐伊人憔悴
狼牙月本身就是修辞学
他用到了魔写模仿的模模写
这是视觉模写
我们对于已知事物的感受去相呼应的对象
这个对象可能是听觉的
可能是视觉的
可能是嗅觉
可能是味觉
可能是触觉
那狼牙乐很明显是视觉
所以叫视觉模写
月亮基本上可能是明月吧
然后明月是有颜色的
上弦月是有形状的
然后基本上很少人用狼牙去比喻月亮的颜色
我之所以用狼牙月伊人憔悴
是因为呢狼牙象征着一种战乱
伊人憔悴
你憔悴怎么去呼应明月明月很圆满嘛
那就不对了
所以我琢磨了很久
干脆用狼牙
为什么狼牙
野狼的牙齿有个最大的犬齿是弯曲的
那那个弯曲的牙齿是米白色的
因为野狼是肉食性动物嘛
牙齿不不可能是雪白的
有点米黄
那这种米黄就是我想象中的狼牙月
这是月亮的颜色
叫狼牙月
所以这句话用到的默写视觉魔写
再来是我举杯饮尽了风雪
我举杯引进的风学用到两个
一个是转化
一个是夸式
什么是转化呢
转化你可以理解成
不见得一定是把物件比喻为人
有时候是物件比喻为物件
就是换换一个物件而已
有时候是以物拟人
有时候是以人迷雾
所以不见得是一定是拟人化
所以才叫转化
武举杯饮尽了风雪
风雪怎么引进呢
基本上就把风雪你能化了
而且我引进了风水
一口把风雪都喝掉
气吞山河的感觉
这个就是夸式
修辞学里面的夸式是最好理解的
我举杯哦
饮尽了风雪
这是多气派啊
是很潇洒的感觉
这个叫夸式
所以他用到了两个修辞学
一个是转化
一个是夸视
第三啊
是是谁打翻前世柜惹尘埃是非
这个就是设问就是是谁
这两个字是色问诶
到底是谁
是疑问的意思就是设问修辞学里面讲色问好
这是第三行
你所没哭
红颜唤不回
这里面用到的拟人化红颜
他不是人嘛
你就哭哭红颜回不来了
所以哭红颜唤不回
呼唤呼唤红颜回来
那既然红颜他不是人的话
那这句话就是转化里面转化有分三种
物转物
人转物
然后物转人
这个是物转人
就是把物拟人化
这个用到了转化这个修辞
再还是纵使青史已燃成灰
我爱不灭
这里面的青史
青史就是历史
他就是夸视
纵使青史已然成灰
青石怎么会成灰呢
整个历史在运作是你一个人说了算吗
所以非常的夸式
黄河之水天上来
奔流到海不复返
这个都是跨世哪里
这黄河之水怎么可能从天上来了
所以古诗词的韵味就是这么的有趣
它可以有各种意象的包含
繁华如3000东流水
这句歌词用到了两个修辞
一个是譬喻
一个是花式
譬喻是用已知的固定事物来对比
来象征抽象的事物
因为繁华很好理解
繁华就是繁荣嘛
就是红尘间的一个都市啊
很很熙来攘往的人群嘛
但是3000东流水是什么东西
就他是抽象的
所以譬喻是用繁华去譬喻3000东流水
然后夸式是3000东流水
我只取一瓢爱了解
只恋你化身的蝶
这里面用到两个修辞
一个是转化
我刚有强调转化是很多
有三种
这里面的转换化是用到以物拟物
我只取一瓢
爱了解一瓢
它不是具象的
我只取一瓢爱了解
所以他只颠覆了他物件的本身的认知
只恋你化身的点是譬喻
就是我很明显很清楚
就是人称代名词
你化身的蝶就有点抽象
你你化身什么
你化身蝴蝶啊
化身螳螂吗
哦这是譬喻
用已知的事物去对比抽象的事物叫譬喻
接下来我们进入副歌咯
你发如雪
凄美了
离别用到两个修辞
一个是譬喻
譬喻什么呢
你的头发像雪一样的白
叫发如雪
然后凄美了
离别凄美是形容词凄美的离别
形容词转动词叫转品
把词性转换叫转品
下一句是我焚香感动了谁
这个是刚刚我用过的色问疑问句
设问我焚香感动了谁
这个谁就是色问
只是说有些色问在前面
有些在后面
下一句歌词是邀明月让回忆皎洁
这个叫转品磁性的转换
刚刚有介绍过
里面转换的关键字是脚结
皎洁是形容词
但是要明月让回忆皎洁
回忆皎洁
它就变动词了
所以形容词变动词
副歌最后一句是爱在月光下完美
这个也是转品里面的关键字是完美
形容词转名词
因为他已经ending了嘛
爱在月光下完美
完美版是形容
但是他在月光下完美了
所以他变成名词了
这也是转品
第二段副歌
你发如雪
纷飞的眼泪
记得哦
纷飞的眼泪就是默写视觉魔血
下一句是我等待苍老了
谁跟刚刚一样苍老了
谁形容词变动词我苍老了
谁只是转品
红尘醉微醺的岁月只是转化
那这里面的关键字是红尘醉微醺的岁月
微醺的岁月没有休止血
它是一种形容微醺的岁月
但是红尘醉红尘怎么会醉呢
哦那就是红尘变成人了
所以是物转人叫拟人化
最后一句歌词是我用无悔刻永世爱你的碑
这个是转化
而且这个转化很特别是物转物哦
因为无悔怎么能磕悲呢
就是把无悔形容成可以雕刻悲死的一种误解
所以我用无悔刻永世爱你的碑
所以这里面的转化是物转物
各位同学
刚刚我听清楚哈
修辞学
这是古风歌曲的大补帖
也是中国风歌曲的武林秘籍
刚刚逐字的讲解很清楚哦
现在要讲快一点哦
现在讲的是青花瓷
素胚勾勒出青花
笔
锋浓转淡
这句话没有用到修辞学
瓶身描绘的牡丹
一如你初妆这句话就有瓶身描绘的牡丹
很好理解
是已知的事物
例如你初妆
就是把已知的事物跟比较抽象的事物去对比
叫譬喻再来
冉冉檀香透过窗心事